where the recent release of video games
like God of War Ragnarok or the
popularity of TV series like Vikings the
culture and mythology of pre-christian
Scandinavia has once again become quite
a hot topic of interest for a lot of
people and this is of course totally
understandable because this is a
fascinating world of different Gods
creatures Heroes and stories about all
these characters that have crept into
popular culture during the last couple
of years
but what do we actually know about the
religion or perhaps religions of the
ancient Nordic peoples based on
archeology and actual scholarship how
much of what we see in movies or games
or or is actually accurate and how did
the actual people who lived in this
culture and in this region at that time
conceive of and practice their religion
today we're going to focus on the
incredibly fascinating topic of Old
Norse religion
[Music]
me
anymore
not when I say Nordic religion I'm of
course referring to something rather
specific because religion in Scandinavia
today is a very varied category there
are various different religions
Christianity Islam Hinduism all kinds of
religions exist in the Nordic countries
and so when we say Nordic religions or
at least when I say it in this context
I'm of course talking about the religion
that existed in this region primarily
before the arrival or at least the the
dominance of Christianity you know the
religion with characters like Odin and
Thor and the big snake and idrisil and
Iron Man now obviously when we're
dealing with an entire religious
tradition or maybe even traditions in
this case that existed for many
centuries and obviously also changed
across those centuries from time and
from in different places also it's
impossible to cover properly or to to
cover it with a single
coherent narrative so to say we will
have to
focus in on specific things but as
always the strategy in this episode is
to give a very general overview of this
religious and cultural tradition and
then hopefully we can dive deeper into
specific topics in later episodes the
Norse peoples believed in a multitude of
different gods and superhuman beings it
was in other words what we often call a
polytheistic religion
the different gods and their family
lions were often conceived of in very
human ways they had personalities they
could act in questionable ways they
fight they fall in love they have sex
they get cheated on Etc in other words
their idea of gods appears similar to
other ancient polytheistic religions
such as that in ancient Greece or
perhaps ancient Egypt and so on and
indeed the religious cults and many of
the myths in the Nordic countries are
part of a wider Indo-European heritage
there are often direct connections
between myths and deities in the Nordic
countries and other places from the
neighboring Germanic peoples all the way
to Greece Persia and even India this can
be seen for example in the names of the
Gods the Greek name for God or deity
feos is directly connected to the name
of the highest God in that Pantheon the
Greek pantheon Zeus or Jupiter in Roman
religion this word becomes dios in Latin
it is connected with the Sanskrit term
for the gods Devas Etc
and the Norse god tear derives
etymologically directly from that word
thus sharing Origins with Zeus even
though tear plays a much different role
in the Norse pantheon than Zeus does in
the Greek one
in any case the gods played a central
role in the daily lives and societal
structure for the ancient Norse peoples
the world was filled with supernatural
creatures not just Gods but Giants elves
wetter and much else and all with their
special place in the cosmology a cosmos
that should be kept in its proper order
the gods were a powerful group of beings
and existed in different lines and
different kinds there was the Acer which
included most of the gods that we know
such as Odin Thor and balder but there
was also another race of gods called the
vanir which included figures like freyr
and Freya sometimes all of the gods are
referred to with the name Acer but in
reality they belong to either one of
these two lions these gods were powerful
beings that at least most of them lived
in Asgard and the human beings who
inhabited the realm of midgard needed to
make sure the gods were happy in order
to keep the order and so that they could
be protected for this reason humans
perform various rights such as offerings
sacrifices and other cultic practices as
a form of worship and exchange
in turn the gods had to protect
themselves as well as human beings
sometimes from the inhabitants of utgaud
sometimes jotenheim which included the
arch enemies of the Gods the yotan or
Giants we will dive deeper into the
actual cosmology and mythology of this
system later on but this is the general
outline one that of course reminds us a
lot about other polytheistic religions
from different parts of the world
[Music]
foreign
but how do we know what we know about
ancient Norse religion what are the
sources from which Scholars draw all
this information
well this is as always a rather
complicated question but also one that
is of course very important and Central
there are a few key sources that
Scholars look to first of all
stores here first of all there is the
archaeological findings so this would be
places or objects that have survived
from that period this could be things
like gravesites or maybe a statue or
cultic objects that would have been used
and which can give us Clues as to how
this religion or these religions were
actually practiced back then and then of
course there are runestones or runic
inscriptions like this one here this is
the Yash Berg stone or yes
in Western Sweden it's from the 6th
Century
which is which means it's one of the
earliest examples of one of the earliest
surviving runestones in all of Sweden
which can be seen for example by the
fact that the script used here the runes
are actually the so-called older futarch
so the older script before this large
linguistic and cultural shift took place
in the 6th 7th Century this is a really
fascinating Stone the ruins themselves
Scholars know basically what it says but
they disagree on some some details and
some some implications to what I said
essentially it's just a guy
saying something like this is my name
this is what I'm called and I have
written these runes so he might have
been some sort of brunic expert or
ritual expert of some sort we we aren't
sure of course I think Jackson Crawford
has made an excellent video he was here
I think last year
um made a video about this very Stone so
if you want more details about this uh
runestone in particular you can probably
advise his video just like this one
wounded conscriptions are usually rather
short but um in my opinion at least
aesthetically pretty beautiful
and short as they may be they often also
include important Clues important
details about the gods the myths even
historical events and sometimes the the
runes will have images in them like
actual images this one doesn't it's a
very simple one with simply with with a
futarch script but
some of them will include image images
so runes are also a very important
source for or source of information for
uh for ancient Norse religion and
culture thirdly there are place names so
there are certain places in Scandinavia
and Sweden there are named after the
Gods like wooden plan and Stockholm for
example or words that have
names that have these words as suffixes
like uh like hoab or or Lund v v that
are words that indicate that these
places may have been used for ritual or
cultic practices in history and then of
course there are the literary sources so
this would be poems stories and sagas
that would have been told
recited basically during special
occasions uh in in ancient times or in
medieval times and then they would have
been written down much later usually in
the Middle Ages and the most famous and
like widely considered of of these
sources are the so-called Ada
and there are two kinds of Eda
essentially first there is the prose
Adder also known as the Elder Eda and
this is a collection of poems
essentially from different time periods
and different places and the only reason
why we considered it a what we
considered a sort of a whole a single
work is because we find these poems
basically most of them at least in a
single manuscript what is called the
Codex wigius which was compiled around
the 13th century
um and again these stories or the poems
include a lot of the most famous stories
and sagas about the heroes the gods you
know Ragnarok the the the creation of
the world all these stories that we know
and love are included in a lot of these
poems uh the dating of the poems are
uncertain some of them may have been
written or composed or at least edited
in post-christian times and would have
been maybe influenced by things like
Christian theology whereas others
probably date from much earlier maybe as
early as the 8th Century or maybe even
earlier than that
so that's the poetic era then secondly
there is the prose era also known as
snories Adda and it's called this
because it was essentially written by
the 13th century Icelandic Christian
monk snorri sterlason
in Swedish he would have written this
work
sometime around 12 20 or at least in the
early to mid 13th century and it's
essentially this work is is intended to
show students how to write scaldic
poetry but in the process Nori actually
includes a lot of important stories and
myths from the Norse tradition which
makes this a very important Source there
is also a more advanced form of poetry
known as scaldic poetry which was
composed by by Poets called scalds and
this is often considered a very high
literary and aesthetic achievement at
least compared to the others so these
poems are very beautiful a lot more
advanced in that sense but there there
there's no collection in the sense of
the poetic Eda for instance of these
skull The scaldic Poetry
um so these poems are scattered all over
different places and from different
times but still
another important source as well as many
other famous sagas like the The volsunga
Saga the song of the Volo songs for
instance so all of these kind of stories
and sagas and poems are important
literary sources that we use to to get
some idea of the culture and religion of
the ancient nors but then there are also
of course certain outside sources so
um
we can consult sources like Roman
writers that would have described the
culture and religion of the Germanic
peoples there are
stories by Christian missionaries that
would have been sent into northern
Europe to to spread Christianity and
they also tell us a lot about the
culture that they encountered and there
is also the uh the the the the the
accounts of the famous Arab traveler IBN
fadlan
now these sources of course need to be
viewed critically to some degree and
approached carefully because of the
inherent bias that they probably contain
because they're written by again by
Outsiders by people who were often also
critical of this religion or this
culture but still they they can be
consulted as long as we do it
scientifically and and with a critical
sort of historical critical mind those
are also some important sources
almost all of these sources with the
exception of a few runic inscriptions
are from the period after a major
cultural and linguistic shift that
occurred around the 6th century when the
language of Scandinavia saw major
changes and the religious cult seems to
become more influenced by the Germanic
Neighbors in the south
any information about the religious
tradition before the 6th century is
therefore even harder to say anything
about with certainty except for a few
educated guesses so what we can and will
focus on in this episode is therefore
religion as it was practiced during what
is known as the Viking age so this is
between the 8th Century to the 11th 12th
century is roughly basically So based on
all of these sources that I have just
described to you what do we actually
know about religion in ancient
Scandinavia
foreign
[Music]
we have already covered some of the
basics it was a polytheistic religion
full of many gods deities and other
superhuman creatures and a mythology
packed with fascinating stories about
giant snakes Giants the end of the world
drinking parties and much else
needless to say the ancient Nordic
people lived a life that was totally
infused with this religious tradition
the gods were very real forces in
people's lives however they may have
interpreted them and there was an order
to existence in which gods and humans
figured that needed to be kept in order
through ritual practices
now as we've talked about in earlier
episodes we have to approach myths and
mythology from the proper perspective
today in our culture so influenced by
the abrahamic religions were used to
there being a single definite version of
events when it comes to the origin of
the world or in different sacred myths
this is not the case for most of the
ancient mythologies myths are stories
that are always changing and being
altered based on the context many
different versions of a story that still
convey the same truth or message so when
we look at our sources for Norse
mythology we aren't surprised to see a
huge diversity
to some extent we can't even really
consider the ancient Norse religion to
be a quote-unquote religion at all if by
that we mean a sort of unified whole
with certain characteristics a model for
religion that we are used to from the
abrahamic framework instead it's all
more of an interconnected web of
religious phenomena that could look very
different from place to place from
Community to community and in different
times
different people conceptualized and
perform their religious beliefs and
practices in different and diverse ways
there are many different versions and
conflicting accounts when it comes to
mythology for example which makes it
hard to paint a complete or systematic
picture
we can look at the main sources we have
such as the poetic Eda and base our
generalizing discussion on that but we
must be aware that this is an incomplete
picture and there are many more
variations on any given subject
the ancient noise people saw themselves
as living in a reality made up of
different worlds or Homes at the very
center of the world is Asgard the home
of the gods or at least the Acer gods
and at the very center of Asgard
therefore at the very very center of the
cosmos is the giant tree known as
iggdrasil this is perhaps the most
common symbol for Norse religion as a
whole this tree kind of represents the
tree of life it's a kind of axis around
which the World Turns and from which
everything happens since it is the Gods
in Asgard that in a way creates the
world
tree symbolism is very common in
religions around the world as it kind of
axis Mundi or center point of the world
and as representing life itself and
Norse mythology is no different igdrasil
takes nourishment from the well at its
roots where we also find the mythical
figures called norns three of which are
named urdur verdani and skulld which
makes sure that the tree is nourished
and also is responsible for weaving the
threads of Fate thus representing the
life threads or fates of human beings
and the world
the tree then takes that nourishment and
spreads it to the world as its branches
stretch far and wide it's a profound
image in any case outside of Asgard that
Central world of the Gods we have the
world where humans live which is called
midgard
as the name suggests this is a world in
the middle between Asgard and the world
or worlds outside you can kind of
imagine this world as concentric circles
with Asgard at its Center outside of
which is midgard where humans live and
outside of midgard is a place with more
obscure names one of which is utkarth
which literally means something like the
outside world or outside place
this is where all the other forces and
beings live forces that often oppose the
Gods in Asgard especially the gods Arch
enemies the yotan or Giants
thus utgard is sometimes used
synonymously with the word yotenheim the
home of the Giants but at other times it
seems that jotenheim is simply a part of
the larger category of utkart in this
picture the world we live in midgard
kind of stands between the gods and
Asgard and their enemies on the other
side which become significant of course
for our role in the cosmos this is a
very general outline but there is also
often talk about the nine worlds Asgard
and midgard being only two of these nine
indeed in the voluspa the first poem in
the poetic Eda and one of the most
famous Norris text which recounts the
whole history of the cosmos from
creation to its end in Ragnarok the
vulva or Seer describes it thus using
the translation of my YouTube colleague
and Scholar Jackson Crawford quote I
remember the Giants born so long ago in
those ancient days they raised me
I remember nine worlds nine giantesses
and the seed from which igdrasil sprang
we don't get much more than that about
these worlds so this is somewhat of an
obscure topic but some Scholars have
suggested identifications for them based
on mentions in other sources if you've
played God of War for example these will
sound familiar to you they are Asgard
and midgard of course vanheim homavy
veiner group of Gods
alfheimer the home of the elves
iotenheim where the Giants live moose
spells Heim which is a realm of fire
SWAT alfheim homobi SWAT Alpha which
means the black elves nifilheim a cold
and dark place sometimes identified with
hail the realm of the dead and neither
valer which is the home of the dwarves
again the relationship of these worlds
and their place Etc is often uncertain
but their names already give you an
indication of the kinds of beings that
occupy the Norse mythology aside from
humans and gods there are elves Giants
dwarves and much else so this is now
quite a complex cosmology the world has
igdrasil and Asgard at its center from
which it Springs outward into the
different worlds and at the very end of
the world in the farthest reaches of
utgaard there's the absolutely giant
snake or midgard serpent that encircles
the whole world and keeps it together
if this snake who is actually a child of
Loki and anger Boda would die or be
disturbed the whole world would fall
apart the snake in his oroboros form
biting his own tail which represents
things like eternity is Central to Norse
cosmology as he's responsible for
holding the whole Cosmos together and
will play an important role in Ragnarok
as well
[Music]
and that's another thing that is so
fascinating about Norse mythology that
the whole history of the world basically
is already mapped out and we can find
this in the sources from the birth of
the universe and the gods themselves all
the way to the end it's a kind of
inevitable cycle that is going to happen
Ragnarok is coming and the gods need to
prepare
but let's back up a bit first where does
all this begin
at the beginning of everything before
there was a world or any gods or really
anything there was a primordial void or
chaotic State called
from this void there appeared two beings
a giant primeval being called Emir and
the Primeval cow dungla now a few things
happen next from emir's body there are
born other beings namely the first
giants
Emir is in other words the ancestor to
all the Giants
meanwhile our doombla starts licking the
salt from rocks until it appears the
head of a man this was Buri and the
start of another line of beings in turn
buddhi then somehow has a son called Bor
eventually Bor and one of The Offspring
of Emir besla get it on so they say and
they have children
three of them in fact called Odin Villi
and Vera the first Gods so already from
this beginning we have two lines of
beings the Giants and the gods but at
the same time the gods are also created
as offsprings of both Emir and aodumblan
so it's a little confusing but this
these two lines of beings have always
existed since this beginning and they've
basically always been fighting in any
case the three God Brothers eventually
Rebel and decide to kill Emir and from
his body they create the world as we
know it his legs are mountains his blood
becomes the waters his flesh becomes the
Earth Etc
not only does this explain the cosmic
origin of the great conflict between
gods and Giants after all the Giants
will forever be pretty pissed that Odin
and his brothers killed their father but
it also connects with many other
cosmicondic myths from around the world
from tiamats in ancient Mesopotamia to
India and even in Egyptian mythology we
find the idea that the world was
fashioned from the body of some Divine
or primordial being so this is basically
the origin of the world and of the gods
they are creations and offspring of Odin
and his brothers and so at this point
the gods will want to settle down and
Asgard and just enjoy their time right
but unfortunately something goes away
when suddenly there appears three female
Giants that really throws the gods for a
loop now this account which is from the
Ebola Spa is really mysterious and
strange and it's hard to interpret but
what is clear is that with the
appearance of these three female Giants
the the gods are really thrown in for a
loop they they have
there's a war that happens suddenly now
because of this war between the gods and
the Giants the gods are forced to create
new beings to help them in this fight
against their enemies so they create the
dwarves for example and there's a long
line of of dwarf figures in the voluspa
the dwarves are basically created as
beings that that build weapons that
create weapons for the gods to fight and
then of course it is at this point that
the gods also create the human being to
be an aid basically to be to be of help
to the gods the story of the creation of
the human being differs in our different
sources in the evolu spa it seems to
imply that the human being was created
by the dwarves at least the human form
was created by the dwarves and with with
Earth and it then the gods blue
Spirits into the human basically in
snories prose Ada however we are told
that the gods created human beings from
two tree trunks whatever the case both
of these stories agree that it was three
gods that were responsible for the
creation of the human being Odin is
always involved no matter which story
but the other characters differ so in
the
um in snory's account it is Odin and his
two brothers who we met earlier vile and
ve whereas in the voluspa it is two
other gods so it's Odin honir and Loth
in both stories there are also two
original human beings ask and embla and
both of these names seem to refer
etymologically to trees again going back
to the tree metaphor somehow that human
beings came from trees were connected to
trees in some way the name ask is in
fact the name of a particular tree
unfortunately this is not an usk but the
ask tree is very important in Norse
mythology because indeed the tree
igdrasil in the middle of Asgard is one
such tree but it's a very big ask tree
this etymology is indeed interesting
because it might if we could speculate a
little bit it might at least refer to
some kind of connection between igdrasil
the the large ask tree as the sort of
axis Mundi of the universe and the human
being as some sort of maybe maybe
there's some kind of microcosm macrocosm
situation going on here since the first
human being at least the male version is
called usk and that is all also the name
for the can of tree that we find in the
middle of asgar that sort of stretches
the branches across the whole world and
it's really responsible for
for the maintenance of the world in many
ways it is the place that the entire
world revolves around and this is the
the kind of tree that is here is
reflected in the name of the first human
being this is a really interesting
connection I think in the Volus body
event is described thus quote three Gods
powerful and passionate left Asgard for
midgard they have found ask and embla
weak fateless in that land
they had no breath no soul no hair no
voice they looked inhuman Odin gave them
breath honier gave them Souls loaf gave
them hair and human faces at this point
we've kind of reached the world as it
stands today and the Adas and all the
other sources we have contain many many
stories about these gods and humans and
the relationships between them way too
many stories to go through in a short
episode like this of course but as we
said earlier the mythology of the
ancient Nordic peoples also included a
vision of the inevitable future because
indeed the gods and all other beings
have to prepare for a cataclysmic event
called Ragnarok that is coming in the
future this event will be inaugurated by
the death of Odin's favorite son balder
at the hands of Loki which is Odin's
adoptive brother and this will set in
motion a chain of events that will
culminate in what is known as Ragnarok
where the Giants led by Loki and the
midcoin serpents and fenvir who is this
giant wolf creature will engage in a
cataclysmic war where the gods where
everyone will basically kill everyone
Odin will be swallowed by fenrir but
then Avenged by his son Thor is going to
battle The midgard Serpent and both are
going to kill each other basically no
one survives this event and it throws
the world into complete destruction
but there is light at the end of the
tunnel because the voluspa also hints
that after Ragnarok there will be a kind
of renewal right a new world is going to
Rise From the Ashes of the old one the
vulva says quote I see the Earth rise a
second time from out of the sea green
once more
waterfalls flow and Eagles Fly overhead
hunting for fish among the mountain
peaks the Acer meets on ifable and
regard the bones of the midgard serpent
and there they recall the great events
of Ragnarok and Odin's old wisdom
the poem which recounts a story spanning
from the creation of the Gods in the
universe to its end and rebirth and
where the haunting words quote I see a
hall standing there more beautiful than
sunlight thatched with gold at gimla
their bold men will dwell and enjoy
cheer throughout their lives then the
dark dragon will come flying down from
the dark mountains that glistening
serpent knit hog will bear corpses in
his wings as he flies over that Valley
now I must retire
this is just a general account of some
of the most popular and commonly retold
aspects of the Norris mythological
accounts and in this world there were
many many different gods that humans
turn to to Worship in different ways the
humans saw themselves as living in this
world a world full of different again
gods and Giants and and large snakes and
all kinds of creatures that were very
much real to them and which um shape
their lives in many ways all of these
myths and these stories and these these
um characters were very real and and
prominent aspects of people's lives in
the Nordic countries at this time and
life was in many ways characterized by
this constant relationship with these
gods and other forces in the universe
now as we've said in previous episode
about basically any religion that isn't
the big abrahamic ones it's important to
keep in mind that myths and beliefs
aren't necessarily as important as we
may assume to think that religion is
primarily about what someone believes is
a very Christian and even Protestant
Christian way of looking at the subject
to the ancient Norse peoples just like
in many other traditions in the world
the stories and myths and what they
believed so to say wasn't the central
aspect of religion at all there was no
Creed to believe in no dogma and Forest
that were seen as Orthodox quote unquote
and these things were very fluid and
diverse as we saw before often when we
talk about these topics we sometimes
divide religions into religions of
Orthodoxy or white belief literally and
orthopraxy right practice and if we were
to categorize Norris religion ancient
Norse religion into one of these two
they would definitely fall into the
latter into orthopraxy because
when it comes to the religion of these
people it was much more about what you
did rather than what you believed right
believing in the myths or the stories or
in the gods it wasn't so much about the
belief that was that was an aspect of it
of course but it was much more about
what you did your relationship to the
gods the offerings you made to them the
rituals you performed this becomes
perhaps most clear when we realized that
there wasn't any equivalent word to our
religion in the language of the ancient
Scandinavians the maybe closest
equivalent we have is the word uh well
as the word said
which means something close to a custom
or or perhaps uh
well I think a customer is a pretty
pretty good translation of it and late
in later Christian times it will it
would also be referred to as fun which
means basically old custom and what's so
important about this word or the
connotation that word is that it's very
practical in nature right custom it
means something that you do something
that you did so this is very very
different from how we maybe conceive of
religion especially in a Christian or
Protestant context where religion is
very much about belief or faith
foreign
[Music]
so what did they actually do then
well the relationship with the gods and
other forces were maintained through
things like offerings and various kinds
of invocations the cult was performed on
a public and private level but often
took similar forms
Society in ancient Scandinavia and
during the Viking age was strongly
family based life was centered on the
homestead a plot of land where a family
would live together at least if they
were wealthy enough and within a family
there would be religious practices
performed
as is usually the case the different
important life events were accompanied
by rituals and Customs birth for example
involved different processes in which
one sought help from higher powers like
freyja who was the goddess associated
with fertility among other things
similar proceedings took place in
connection with weddings as well as the
death of a person
upon death a person would be buried
often along with important belongings
and objects in a grave close to the
homestead in this way the dead even
though they were not physically present
still played a role in the life of the
family indeed there seems to have been a
pretty strong custom of ancestor worship
families would make offerings at the
gravesite of ancestors give them food or
poor beer or ale over the grave the dead
were thus not completely annihilated but
lived on in some kind of afterlife and
the family maintained a relationship
with the deceased in this way
as for where the dead would go after the
demise of the body there are many
different accounts and versions the most
famous afterlife concept is probably
that of hail ruled over by the goddess
of the same name this was a kind of
shadowy Realm where the souls of the
deceased would live after death and it
doesn't sound all that exciting it's
pretty similar to the Jewish concept of
shio in the Hebrew Bible or aralu in
ancient Mesopotamia
another famous place that dead people
could go is Valhalla this was the home
of Odin in particular and associated
with Warfare and warriors it was
soldiers or people who died in combat
that ended up here in particular and
would continue to serve that role as
soldiers fighting for Odin and the gods
and Ragnarok but there are also other
possible kinds of afterlife in this
culture such as helgafel a beautiful
mountain you could go to the ocean with
the goddess Iran and even some sort of
Realm ruled over by freyja this is a
good example to show the diversity and
complex way that religions lack this
function there could exist various
different ideas about something like the
afterlife at the same time without that
being necessarily a problem there was no
Dogma in that sense then people
conceived of things in different ways in
any case the homestead and family home
also included other kinds of rituals
some of them included the gods that we
know and love for example there seems to
have been different practices that we
could refer to as quote-unquote magic
when a woman was to give birth a ritual
expert might perform some sort of
magical spell of protection which could
of course involve the Gods
there were different forms of divination
where sacred sticks would be thrown in
the air and then the placement in which
they landed would be interpreted to
foretell future events and much else
just like in so many other cultures
protective amulets were used by Everyday
People these could involve runes which
was the kind of writing used by these
people that we've seen But was also
thought to contain certain magical
powers another common amulet it seems
was to wear a miniature version of
Thor's hammer mjolnir around your neck
which would presumably invoke the
protection of the god Thor different
gods were of course associated with
different things and so would be invoked
for different purposes
Odin is obviously one of the most
Central gods and indeed often seen as
the most powerful or the sort of leader
of the Gods we saw in the creation
account that he is one of the original
ancestors of all the gods and he does
have a kind of leader position in the
mythology
he's a very versatile God associated
with many different things called by
many names and going under different
disguises Odin often visits human
without them realizing it he visits them
in disguise
even in the eras he is called by
different names which can get pretty
confusing for those not familiar with
the mythology and all these different
names and traditions but in his most
quote-unquote original or True Form he
is often depicted with only one eye with
his two Ravens hugin and Moomin and has
a famous eight-legged horse named
sleepnet Odin is the god of warfare and
offerings to him would be made before
battles for example
but he's also the god of poetry the god
of said something close to shamanic
practice and the god of wisdom
specifically the mystical wisdom
associated with death and runes in fact
there is a very famous account in the
habamal one of the stories in the poetic
Eda where Odin hangs himself in the
world SRI thus being able to acquire the
mystical knowledge of death and learn
the secrets of the runes a very
fascinating god with many sides but
while Odin is obviously a very important
God it seems to many scholars that he
probably wasn't as popularly worshiped
as you might expect
indeed while Odin seems to have been
popular among the elites and specific
groups like Warriors or poets to most
quote-unquote regular people other gods
were more popular such as Thor freyr and
Freya
Thor is Odin's son and a god of great
strength he's associated with thunder
and has the role of upholding the order
of the world together with his famous
Hammer mjolnir he often battles Giants
and other enemies to keep the world in
order he even has a few run-ins with the
midgard serpent like in the famous and
quite comical scene where he
accidentally catches the giant snake
while out fishing one time His companion
then has to keep him from fighting and
killing the serpent which would make the
world fall apart and what really does
kind of go against his whole purpose as
the god of keeping the world together
Thor was a very popular God and we have
many figurines and other references to
him across Scandinavia
as we saw it was also popular among
people to carry his hammer around their
neck as a kind of amulet there are also
the gods freyr and Freya brother and
sister who are associated with similar
themes and belong to that other group of
gods the vanir
freyr is a god of harvest Agriculture
and fertility often invoked in context
where those themes are relevant like in
springtime for instance his association
with fertility can be seen from his
depiction often including an erect penis
Freya likewise is one of the most
interesting of the Gods she might have
very old origins in the religious
traditions of Scandinavia maybe even
older than the other Indo-European
deities
like her brother she's a goddess of
fertility a goddess of sex love and
eroticism but she's also more versatile
than that
similar to Odin she's the goddess of
seder a kind of mystical practice that
was usually performed and associated
with women in particular
she's also a goddess of death and rules
over one kind of afterlife that we
mentioned earlier the famous
mythological stories frequently involve
freyja thus perhaps the most Central and
popular of the goddesses in Norse
mythology
there are many other gods or divinities
that we could talk about but these are
some of the most prominent and popular
ones we can explore the pantheon more in
detail in future episodes but while the
gods were obviously very important and
played a major role in the private
sphere the other forces in the universe
also played a major role indeed The
Scholar Guru stian's land argues that in
the private sphere of the homestead
rituals involving other Collective
forces like elves for instance were a
lot more prominent than those evolving
the actual Gods the latter of whom
played a bigger role in the public cult
which we will get to soon
for example there was a collective group
of beings called the veter which were
Supernatural Spirits or creatures that
lived and protected the land
in particular the can referred to as
land Vetter were thought to be Guardian
creatures of a particular location
any place had a number of veter that
looked after it they could reside in
waters Creeks rocks or caves and it was
the responsibility of people to keep the
veter happy to stay on good terms with
them and to respect them
thus many sources tell us of how female
members of the family would leave
offerings of food and drink to the
Vetter a practice that seems to have
survived long after christianization
if the people who resided in a
particular location kept the veter happy
that would also benefit them in
different ways perhaps their crops would
be fruitful for example but if you
got on the vector's bad side maybe your
crops would would not be so happy
so the private sphere was filled with
religious rituals but what about the
public how did Society come together to
maintain their relationship with the
Gods
[Music]
thank you
the most Central and important ritual
was probably the bloat now this was
essentially a ritual sacrifice where the
community would come together at set
times of the year and make offerings to
the Gods there were three major Blues
festivals of the Year there was one in
springtime which would basically
celebrate the coming of the the summer
months and the sort of transition
between winter and summer and in this
ritual Odin was the main God because
Summer meant more more uh seafaring and
more Wars and Odin was particularly good
at helping you with those kinds of
things there was also a Bluetooth in in
the fall which had the opposite function
of basically giving Thanksgiving for the
summer harvests and then all the things
that they had received and preparing for
the darker winter months and this bloat
was more so associated with The God
freyr Who is as we said the god of of
harvest and infertility
and then thirdly was the midwinter bloot
uh probably in connection to the
solstice which was also called by the
name Yule and this is of course really
interesting because there might be
certain aspects of this
um ritual this this tradition that sort
of carried over into the modern
particularly Nordic ways of celebrating
Christmas uh indeed the very name for
Christmas in Swedish today for example
is still you
um and even certain practices like
eating Christmas ham which is a
prominent aspect of Christmas here might
also stem back to pre-christian times
because the pig was associated with the
godfreya and eating the pig or eating
pork might have been an aspect of this
older Yule or winter blood festival so
there's some really interesting
connections there
now the word bloat or blue ta which is
the verb the verbal form of the word
essentially means to sacrifice but also
with connotations of strengthening to
strengthen and this is precisely what
this ritual was it was a way of offering
to and sacrificing to the Gods in order
to strengthen them and also to
strengthen the relationship between the
gods and humans and this could be done
in different ways one could make
offerings of food and drink simply but
more often it was done through animal
sacrifice
uh today animal sacrifice in sort of
neo-pagan movements aren't isn't the
thing so they will offer food and drinks
but back then animal sacrifice was
probably the the main aspect of this
ritual uh and and so animals like horses
and and sheep and goats perhaps would be
sacrificed and then their blood would be
gathered and they would dip the the
Twigs so they would have Twigs and they
would dip them and then spray the blood
on the images or the statues of the Gods
this was of course a communal ritual
where the community would come together
to make offerings to the gods and while
the blood was offered directly to the
Gods in such a way the meat of the
animals were then cooked and shared in
this great feast
um so the meat wasn't wasn't wasted
obviously and this great feast served
both of course to strengthen
relationship within the community but
also the relationship between the
community and and the Gods
so this basically different forms of
offerings and and and sacrifice was the
main
form of religious practice for the
ancient Norris uh the public cult seems
to have been
more so focused on animal sacrifice
whereas the private sphere in the home
this wouldn't have been as this would
have been pretty costly to to offer your
animals in the homestead so in the
private sphere in the homestead
offerings would would rather be through
to food and drinks and not usually not
through animal sacrifice the scholars
even argue that there may be in certain
forms of human sacrifice performed in
ancient Scandinavia this seems to have
been rather uncommon in the Viking age
but more common in the periods before
that but even then we of course have to
be very careful in accepting such claims
because most of our sources come from
later periods written by by Christians
and other people who are often critical
and want to portray these sort of Pagan
religion in the the worst of lights
right but still it seems that human
sacrifice may have been a thing at least
in some point in some periods in ancient
Scandinavia whatever the case these
forms of offerings and sacrifices was
the main religious practice for the
ancient noise and is of course a
practice that reminds us of many other
polytheistic religions by offering to
the gods and strengthening them
maintaining a good relationship between
the community and the Asia as well as a
good balance in social life in general
one could create or achieve a state of
fried peace both literally but also more
in the sense of maintaining social and
Cosmic order perhaps similar to Concepts
like Dharma in Vedic Traditions or Asha
and Zoroastrianism
but where would these rituals take place
you might ask well technically a blood
could be performed anywhere perhaps here
for instance in the hills of uppsala but
usually a ritual would be in some sort
of sacred place or in some location
associated with the gods we have
mentions of places called herger the
meaning of which is somewhat uncertain
but seems to refer to some kind of
cultic place perhaps referring to a heap
of stones or a kind of altar where
rituals would be performed
so when the community was to gather for
a major bloat or indeed for lesser
events too they might gather at one of
these
but many scholars also believe that
there were dedicated buildings but we
could refer to as temples for the Cults
as well
there are references to buildings called
HOV which might fit this description but
Scholars disagree and debate on the
actual role and nature of the so-called
hope
it's possible that conceiving of such a
place is more of an anachronistic way of
finding an equivalent building to the
Christian church but it is also very
possible that such buildings were in use
or at least that there was
that there was a kind of building called
HOV and that rituals would sometimes
take place there
as usual there were ritual cultic
Specialists that were responsible for
leading the public cultic rituals
of course regular people had some sort
of knowledge themselves and would be
responsible for the cult at home but
when it came to the public rituals they
were dedicated personnel
there was a person referred to as the
Tula who seems to have been some kind of
orator and wise Sage a specialist who
knew all aspects of the cult and
mythology on a more practical level we
also had the godi or gudia representing
the male and female form of the same
title respectively and particularly in
an Icelandic context
these were kind of the equivalent to
priests in the ancient Norse religion
they were responsible for leading the
public rituals such as the major bloats
it's also important to distinguish it
from our conception of priest though
these people were not exclusively
dedicated to the cult they weren't
full-time priests so to say instead they
were often also politicians or held
other important roles in society while
simultaneously being ritual experts that
led religious practices
it should also be pointed out that
religion had a strong connection to
political power as it often does it was
likely the king that had ultimate
authority over the cult and made sure
that all the rituals were performed the
king would also participate in rituals
like the blues as well as we can see
from many accounts at the time there is
for example the fascinating account of
the king Hawk on the good who
reluctantly participated in the blood
festival even though he himself had
converted to Christianity which makes
for some really interesting and
sometimes comical scenes
we've also briefly mentioned the
practice known as seder which is a
fascinating one that often defies any
clear explanation
this was a practice that existed
somewhat on the margins of society and
was Associated primarily with a group of
female practitioners known as volvas who
would perform this ritual of Sader in
which they would induce Altered States
Of Consciousness in different ways in
order to to get an insight into the
hidden aspects of reality often they
could travel to different Realms or
different dimensions in the form of an
animal while their sort of human body
remained in place
some would even call this a kind of
mystical experience where these vulvas
would get an insight into past events
and future events and could basically
see or experience things beyond the
regular human senses the evolvas were
thus almost prophetic figures in this
tradition and it was indeed a vulva that
tells the entire story of creation
through to Ragnarok in the
aforementioned voluspa which literally
means something like the prophecy of the
vulva
this practice of say that is primarily
associated with figures like Odin and
Freya who is thought to be the
originator of the practice
it is so interesting that it kind of
deserves a dedicated episode on its own
where we can explore it more in depth
but it did serve as an important orbit
relatively marginal parts of
pre-christian religion in ancient Sammy
mavia
so as you can tell religion in ancient
Scandinavia diverse as it may have been
was something that ran through basically
every aspect of society from the private
rights of Passage and offerings to gods
and other beings performed by families
in the homestead to public rituals of
sacrifice and feasts the very political
structure and authority of the king to
the very way that humans saw themselves
and their place in the world and the
cosmos A World in which they stood in
between Asgard the realm of the Gods and
utgod the realm of all the other forces
the world around them was filled with
these forces and governed by them which
of course had a major impact on all
aspects of life
the stories about the gods and heroes
that we find in the sources like in the
eras are incredibly fascinating and
entertaining and to the people of
pre-christian Scandinavia these stories
were very Central and significant
regardless of how they would have been
interpreted
and while Christianity might have
eventually become the dominant and
official religion in this region in the
first few centuries following the turn
of the first Millennium many aspects of
this old custom lived on some
appropriated by the church and given new
Christian clothing others more perhaps
on the sidelines today there's of course
been a great Resurgence and interest in
and practice of ancient Norse religion
and it's given many different names
everything from ASA true to Norse
paganism and many other names and it's
all part of what is often referred to as
the neo-pagan movement where a lot of
people are sort of rediscovering their
these sort of ancient religions and see
them as alternatives to the more
established religious institutions such
as Christianity so Gods like Odin and
Thor and freyja have once again become
very important spiritual figures and
symbols for many people not just in
Scandinavia but all around the world
people once again gather to perform the
blood ceremonies even though the animal
sacrifice part usually isn't included
today instead including other offerings
such as food and drink in fact I have
previously made a video where I visited
a contemporary group of people
practicing this religious tradition
which they refer to as fun said which
basically means ancient custom you can
check out this documentary on the
channel
as I always say in these videos this has
obviously been a very brief and to some
degree inadequate overview of this
tradition which is of course a lot more
complex and vast than what I have
been able to cover today but like we
said in the beginning the strategy is
that we now have a general overview of
the basics of what this tradition is or
was at least
from a certain perspective and then we
can spend uh later dedicated episodes
diving into more specific topics uh
related to everything that we've talked
about today so if there was anything you
heard today that you would like to know
more about in particular then of course
please leave a comment and tell me so
that we can get into some of those juicy
details about all of this because it's
so so fascinating but for now thank you
all for watching I hope this has been an
interesting and informative video I hope
the Aesthetics of this video has been
especially uh interesting compared to
the way I usually shoot these videos I
thought because I actually live in this
region of the the culture that I talk
about I would take the opportunity to to
use the beautiful natural environment
around me so again thank you all for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]